so secretary of state lincoln dear tony
a very warm welcome i'm very glad to
have you again here in bali
your visit to europe illustrates how
very close the cooperation is between
the european union and the united states
in response to
putin's reckless invasion of ukraine
and thanks to this coordination we have
together designed developed and deployed
sanctions in record time
sanctions that demonstrate our
determination to make putin pay a price
for his war
we do not take these measures lightly
but it is clear we need to act
and with these measures the central bank
cannot use a significant share of its
reserves to defend the ruble now in free
fall
the central bank has had to raise
interest rates by 20 percent
stoking inflation significant commercial
banks are cut off from global markets
and from swift curtailing their ability
to finance the economy
the stock exchange in moscow remains
close since the beginning of this week
one after another western companies
announced their own measures stopping
production investment and sales
the european union and the us
cooperation is at the core of this
effective response
and it has pulled together an
ever-growing number of countries
that apply identical or similar
sanctions our g7 partners uk canada and
japan but also countries like norway
switzerland south korea australia
by now over 40 countries partially or
completely aligned with our sanctions
and this is testimony to the
determination of the global community to
reject this invasion
one only needs to see the result of this
week's united nations generally general
assembly
141 countries an overwhelming majority
supported the resolution condemning
russia for its brutal invasion
only four countries out of 193 stood by
russia it was belarus north korea syria
and eritrea
president putin is increasingly isolated
in the world community
but in the face of the world's protests
putin's army carries on
bombings and missile attacks
on civilian targets are intensifying
register sure
the european union and the united states
will continue to stand by ukraine
and its courageous people and its
steadfast leadership
the scale of the humanitarian
catastrophe there in ukraine that is
unfolding really worries us
europe is seeing destruction and
displacement on a scale not seen since
the darkest days of the last century
the european union as ukraine's neighbor
is sparing no effort
we're providing 500 million euros of
humanitarian aid immediately and more
will come
we're working fast to establish civil
protection hubs in poland and slovakia
and romania
and we are also doing everything we can
with international organizations and
ngos to set up humanitarian corridors
that stretch inside ukraine
desperately needed humanitarian aid must
be able to reach all parts of ukraine
and civilians must be allowed to escape
cities under siege
finally
the european union has triggered for the
first time ever
the so-called temporary protection
directive what is it it effectively
opens up residency rights for most
refugees to live and work in the
european union to have access to health
services or for example schools for at
least a year
we know that this conflict is far from
over
and to be very clear
we are ready to take further severe
measures if putin does not stop and
reverse the war he has unleashed we're
determined we're united and it's a
pleasure to have you here dear tony
madam president ursula thank you um
a short while ago we were meeting with
the
u's foreign affairs council and uh
before that uh at nato and i'll have
more to say about that that later but
with us was uh by video was dimitro uh
koleva the ukrainian foreign minister
and in the course of speaking to us
he showed us some photographs
one of which which i think has also been
in the media
shows
a father
grieving
over his
dead child
blood is still on the
the sheep that drapes him
it's a reminder that
even as we
talk about these weighty issues
of war and peace
what this is really about
is
the lives of men
women
children
hundreds
thousands of individual
human tragedies inflicted
by vladimir putin and his war of choice
on ukraine and its people
and we can't lose sight of that fact
it's also about
an assault on some very basic principles
that we establish together
after two world wars to make sure that
we wouldn't see another one
principles that are the heart of
an international system that
has a responsibility to preserve peace
and security among nations
principles like
the notion that one country sent can't
simply commit acts of aggression on
another changing its borders by force
that one country can't dictate
to another its choices its decisions its
policies with whom it will associate
principles like one country can't exert
a sphere of influence to subjugate its
neighbors to its will
each principle now under assault
by
the aggression against ukraine
committed by
president putin and russia
if
we allow those principles to be violated
with impunity
then
we're opening a pandora's box
in every corner of the world
for this to happen again and again and
again
and the peace and security with all of
the
deficiencies that we've known over the
last 80 years but nonetheless
peace and security that we've been able
to establish
that
will be gone
so the stakes here
are
very real
they're about real lives real people
real human beings
and
they are about large principles
that we have to defend
and we are
and we are in no small measure
because of the extraordinary work
that we've been able uh to do together
the united states and the european union
when
president biden took office one of the
first trips he asked me to make was here
to see you uh to see the leaders
of the european union because president
biden was convinced that
this partnership between us
uh was really
a partnership of first choice
that looking at all of the problems that
our citizens face in their daily lives
uh we would be so much more effective in
dealing with those problems those
challenges and those opportunities
together
not uh not alone not individually and
over the course of this year
um in this effort that we've taken
together to revitalize to re-energize
the partnership between the united
states and european union
we have done
uh some remarkable things in so many
different areas from climate to covid to
emerging technologies
but now
now
we're being tested in a moment of crisis
and
i think that precisely because
we have
invested together in this partnership
we're responding
and we're meeting meeting the tests
as the president said across
so many different areas the support for
ukraine the sanctions against russia
uh the help being provided to people in
distress
uh we're standing up together but i have
to say that
as someone who's watched this uh over
the years both from europe uh and and
from the united states uh i am
it's hard to find the right word for it
but let me simply say it's been almost
overwhelming to see
how quickly how effectively uh the
european union has come together and
acted
in the face of this uh aggression
uh things that none of us thought were
possible
weeks ago
now are reality because
this union
is strong uh it's united uh and it's
acting
and we're grateful to have this
partnership because it is making a
difference
um
i think we know something else and the
president alluded to it
uh unfortunately tragically horrifically
uh
this may not be over soon
and so these efforts that we're making
together we have to sustain them we have
to build upon them
we have to get to the point together and
with
as the president said so many other
countries around the world
who are
united in their abhorrence of what
uh
president putin has unleashed uh we have
to sustain this until it stops until the
war is over the russian forces leave
the ukrainian people regain their
independence their sovereignty their
territorial integrity
we're committed to doing that
thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
you